Washington DC has many problems most
have a D or an R after their names but
thank God the city's tackling the most
pressing problem of all plastic straws
DC now has a plastic straw inspector the
visits restaurants warning them of steep
fines if they don't get rid of the evil
thin hollow tubes being found with a
straw can earn you an eight hundred
dollar fine that's more than the fine
for practicing medicine without a
license in Connecticut don't ask me how
I know
worse it's more bureaucratic harassment
that rattles cashiers and clerks just
trying to do their damn jobs and the
hassle solves no problems the
overwhelming majority of plastic waste
in the ocean which seems to be the
hot-button issue here comes from ten
rivers all from Africa and Asia it ain't
us which poses a problem for left-wing
activists who need an America to protest
mean why all that stuff you separate
ends up back in the landfills
because there's no market to sell the
stuff recycling was sold to us as a
magical solution but even mainstream
media outlets like 60 minutes know it's
garbage
so as usual our nation's busy bodies
ignore the consequences of their actions
plastic straws are necessary for people
with disabilities as well as the elderly
but who cares every band is considered
progress for feverish prigs after all
why should someone possess a product
that makes life easier when the lives of
the activists are so grim
more so than those straws they truly
suck you know what Dana you know eight
hundred bucks in Wyoming Florida and
Mississippi simple assault is a fine of
$500 Wow but it's draw 800 bucks and I
have a straw you're not happy to meet us
the other day when I was in DC what I
didn't get anything with a straw but I'm
going next week for the State of the
Union I'm gonna check it out this
reminds me of when I stockpiled light
bulbs yes four years remember there was
the warning that the light bulbs are
going to with a light bulb lady oh yeah
every time we went to what was that
frege's on Capitol Hill in Washington DC
as it gets some more light bulbs Peter
and then we moved them from DC to New
York yes and they all break during the
move nope and what I feel
about are the are the clerks and the
cashiers yeah I've got to be yelled at
by the customers because they want a
straw yeah and a fine but they know how
to pay the fine oh no paisa okay let me
just say as a resident of the District
of Columbia you can get a straw dana
perino it just won't be a plastic straw
nobody likes it oscillate I'm not but
not it's still not going fat
biodegradable we should have a we should
have them on set tomorrow and start
there five with all of our cups with the
fluency how long they mean I can spit
spit balls through the straw that's like
the dick stuff that's it one the spit
ball is the issue because it gets soggy
with a paper straw you need a plastic
straw for spitballs and some other
things but let's let's not go there
what do you mean Jessie sixty minutes
like was it a couple of months ago was
in December did this piece now I've seen
people john tierney he's written about
this john stossel's written about it
about about the recycling is more
expensive and nobody's buying it and
blah blah blah and they're actually
taking the stuff that you separate out
and they just throw it back in the
landfill this was on 60 minutes so it
may be well coming to our senses well I
was always come to my senses because I
never recycled ever how everything's
coming back full circle and I stayed in
the same that's easy just say it stay in
the same place test don't you love that
the inspectors job sucks yeah I feel bad
for him did you get that joke you missed
the job I already use that joke you
recycled his joke yes here's my honest
opinion now I've flip-flopped on the
plastic straws no I've been lightened
see what it is possible to flip-flop
based on facts if they are getting in
the Potomac yes because they can't be
recycled because they're too small
what's the big deal if you use another
type of biodegradable straw other
industries can pop up and make these
things it's not going to cause a huge
dent in the plastic industry
you just lost that speaking engagement
at the US plastics don't you know what
do you defend these straws okay well
Jesse there's more in the Potomac than
plastic
you're a problem the problem is finding
people I know where you might have
passed our paper tomorrow
I brought a real plastic straw just that
today hmm
I'm wondering if you know the fine for
having a straw is $800 what's the fine
for smuggling straws into the city so
like my brains dried out you saw worse
how much it's like ten straw is
considering high-capacity straw
smuggling oh that's true what I just
said that that I think we should we're
supposed to be you know good stewards of
the earth right right what's wrong with
trying great time for innovation
the current paper straws don't last long
enough so that's annoying so all you
smart whipper snappers out there you
know I have an idea plastic straws
nothing will ever be better China
Indonesia Philippines they all pollute
what plastic they just fill the ocean
with plastics ain't us can we could I
just say one thing wet straws but the
only people that use straws are babies
mm-hmm okay or when you go through a
drive-through so you don't spill or if
you're at like a free drink or something
like that about the ballgame wait a
minute though everybody can drink out of
their glass no no no no no no I'm saving
you a lot of heartache agree with me
when I say this the disabled rely on
plastic yes they do and they should be
able to have access thank you the DC
bill allows them to have there's plenty
I read the bill Greg okay thank you
our house what my mom would actually let
us buy those bendy straws Oh silly
straws they're cool they were great
don't ban those silly straws because it
only silly people will have them don't
know what that meant just do my man ah
the straw man argument again